[Music]
well it's monday monday means it's time
once again for fan corrections
[Applause]
uh fan corrections this is a segment of
course where viewers try to find
mistakes on our show
so far many challengers but no winners
no one has found a mistake on our
program now recently uh the fashion
designer john gagliano was in the news
there he is so i decided to do a live
satellite interview
from paris with his brother the designer
joe galliano
okay
interviewed him live via satellite from
paris well a fan who goes by 12 adam
hunt
says he thinks he caught a mistake
during that interview let's take a look
last week you did a did a bit with the
character i guess
joe galliano
and uh
you guys were doing an interview where
he was supposedly in paris please
welcome live via satellite this from
paris john
galliano
the background you had
behind him
it's clearly light outside
while you tape your show at 5 30 in
california
that would make it three in the morning
in paris it'd be dark outside
so uh
yeah
i consider that a pretty big mistake and
that you would be chumpy
[Music]
i consider it a mistake that you live in
a locker room
seriously
you
and why do you have a video camera in a
men's locker room
that's something else i'm concerned
about
we'll put those matters aside i want to
say sorry 12 adam hunt but it was not a
mistake here to explain why you're wrong
life from paris is fashion designer joe
galliano
good evening joe
von swarken yes
joe can you tell our fans why it is so
bright behind you
in the middle of the night in paris
it's simple
i redesigned nighttime to look like
daytime it's a fabulous switcheroo
you redesigned the daytime to look at
the nighttime how did you find a way to
make it look sunny
in the middle of the night tell me how
you did it
it's easy
i just hired 50 000 street urchins
wrapped them in silver and made human
victory torches
light is the new dark deal with it 12
adam hunt
okay well i have to say mr galliano
that's impressive and you're definitely
live in paris right now is that what
you're telling us of course i am
i'm insulted that anyone would think
otherwise come along street urchin let's
go illuminate the sean's elysee
[Applause]
there you have it pal i was right
and you were wrong